[Music]
spiritual essence is in its simple being
pure consciousness and this
self-consciousness the originally
determinate nature of the individual has
lost its positive meaning of being in
itself the element and the purpose of
its activity it is merely a superseded
moment and the individual is a self in
the form of a universal self conversely
the formal matter in hand gets its
filling from the act of self
differentiating individuality for the
differences within the latter constitute
the content of that universal the
category is in itself or implicit as the
universal of pure consciousness it is
equally for itself or explicit for the
self of consciousness is equally a
moment of it it is absolute being for
that universality is the simple self
identity of being
with paragraph 419 we're entering into a
new subsection or rather sub subsection
of reason this is the second-to-last
it's actually pretty short just ten
paragraphs long and some of those
paragraphs are quite short although two
of them are actually quite long as well
this one is called reason as lawgiver
or D Gazette's gaben de ferran effed
pretty straightforward translation there
and what is reason giving laws to that's
something that we want to think about
right at the start
so we've already dealt with laws quite a
bit earlier on in the reason section you
remember the very first part of
observing reason right we we saw all
sorts of interesting things reason turns
to the external world and tries to make
sense of it it runs into some problems
when it encounters the organic living
thing then it tries to come up with laws
for that when it gets to human beings it
tries to come up with psychological and
logical laws those are also difficult as
well but we see reason continually or
rather rational self consciousness
continually attempting to to do this and
we also saw a very important discussion
of laws in the force and the
understanding part way way back in the
first major part of the work the
consciousness section that was actually
the culmination of it the understanding
was attempting to give laws and at the
same time to figure out where it resided
in relation to these laws and how these
laws were were connected with each other
also in terms of force worlds things
like that here what we see is the
rational self consciousness carrying
forward the project that we we've just
gone through in the entire last section
which was dealing with the Zakas ELPS
tour the translators the heart
matter the matter in hand and we could
think about this as sort of the the
meaningful project by which the self
consciousness was attempting to make
sense of itself in relation to the rest
of the world make sense of itself as a
self consciousness so what we have now
is self consciousness attempting to take
that further remember we had some sort
of resolution at the end of this section
the last section and give itself laws
now why give itself laws does it just
there aren't enough laws out there and
it needs to find a few more no this is a
really architectonic sense this is you
know giving itself rules or norms that
are supposed to make sense not only tell
it what to do but make sense of where it
fits in and what sort of thing it really
is
now Hegel begins by talking about
spiritual essence a term that was
brought up in the end of the last
section guys dig evasion and at the
beginning of this everything is a nice
unity we're gonna see that breakdown as
always seems to happen as we go through
the phenomenology as we as we
dialectically proceed but he begins by
saying that spiritual essence is in its
simple being pure consciousness Vienna
Babu is sane
right this is going to be the universal
as we're gonna see here and it's a
universal self it's not just a bare
abstract universal but it is pure
consciousness and notice that he doesn't
say that it's pure self consciousness at
that point then on the other side he
says it's also this self consciousness
and the self is being stressed there
right this this particular this
individual self consciousness the guy
that I happen to be or whoever it is
that you happen
be watching this right an individuality
so he goes on and he says we've made a
few progresses so the originally
determinate nature of the individual we
saw that as something that was being
worked out in the past section right it
was talked about very early on you have
this original nature like maybe you have
musical talent or you have a penchant
for helping people out because you have
a highly developed sort of naturally
their sense of compassion or you have
some other thing that's motivating you
and it's supposed to flow out of who you
are
Hegel says that this has lost its
positive meaning of being in itself the
element and purpose of its activity so
we're no longer really concerned about
that it's still there it's been sublated
right it's been alcohol burn and it's
there but now it's part of a system now
it's part of something more so he goes
out and he says it's lost its positive
meaning of being in itself the element
and purpose of its activity it's merely
a superseded alcohol bana moment and the
individual is a self in the form of a
universal self which is on this side
over here places conversely here he
starts bringing up form and content
which is going to be playing some role
actually a pretty important role
throughout this this section not always
in exactly the same way but but it's
going to be playing some role so we have
form on this side the side of pure
consciousness we have content on this
side the side of this self consciousness
or individuality so he says the formal
matter in hand gets its filling it needs
filling right from the active self
differentiating individuality the the
person the person acting within the
world which is also a world of culture
and a world of
their self-consciousness so he says the
difference is within the latter
constitute the content of that Universal
now what we want to think about here is
so each individual is conceiving of
itself in relation to this sort of
universal cell for pure pure
consciousness and it projects its own
sort of vision of that then they're on
this side this is split up into a number
of different individual consciousnesses
each of which is going to have its own
viewpoint on what the universal
consciousness is so he says the category
remember we talked about this in the
previous paragraphs is in itself or
implicit when the category here is the
spiritual essence this is in itself this
is implicit that means that it now has
to be unfolded what is the for itself
notice what he says here it's not the
individual but rather pure consciousness
which is here in this case the for
itself he says it's for itself or
explicit right the universal it's the
universal of pure consciousness all
right the self of consciousness is
equally a moment of it so the self the
individual self is being sort of brought
under the heading of something that
strikes us a bit more as abstract but
but we want to keep it from turning into
a mere abstraction so he says it is
absolute being for that universality is
the simple self identity of being and
they are he's talking about this entire
scope right this is absolute being but
do we know yet what absolute being
really is know now we have to explore it
and unfold it and we're gonna find out
that it won't be quite what it what it
promised itself to be at the beginning
because it never is
thus what is object for consciousness
has the significance of being the true
it is and it is authoritative in the
sense that it exists and is
authoritative in and for itself
it is the absolute matter in hand which
no longer suffers from the antithesis of
certainty and it's truth between
universal and individual between purpose
and it's reality but whose existence is
the reality and action of
self-consciousness this matter in hand
is therefore the ethical substance and
consciousness of it is the ethical
consciousness it's object is likewise
for it the truth for it combined
self-consciousness and being in a single
unity it has a value of the absolute for
self consciousness cannot and does not
want anymore to go beyond this object
for in it it is in communion with itself
it cannot for it is all being in all
power it does not want to for it is the
self or the will of this self the object
is in its own self real is object for it
contains within itself the distinction
characteristic of consciousness it
divides itself into masses or spheres
which are the determinate laws of the
absolute essence these masses however do
not obscure the notion for the moments
of being and pure consciousness and of
the self remain and closed within it a
unity which constitutes the essence of
these masses and which in this this
distinction no longer lets these moments
fall apart from one another
things have gotten off to a really
promising start at the beginning of this
section in in paragraph 420
Hegel is going to continue this line of
development in a way that suggests that
now we're finally getting to the core of
what it is to to realize one's life
project to understand where one fits in
now this is by identifying oneself at
this point with the absolute and it's
not going to turn out to be quite so
straightforward or as simple as that of
course but we have to first sort of
climb the hill and then we can start
taking the rollercoaster
all the way down into the dialectical
depth so let's start where where he
starts there's a lot going on in this
paragraph a lot of very abstract
terminology that we're gonna want to
think our way through so he says thus
what is object for consciousness what is
what consciousness is grasping in this
has the significance of being the true
and we're going to see true come up
several times in here this is something
that we've been seeking out the the
entire time there is a sort of continual
AB and flow of beginning with certainty
and then you know working out what's
what's contained within that certainty
and asking the question but is this
certainty true and that eventually
moving on to the true which for Hegel is
never going to be something so
straightforward as just well
correspondence between objects and are
talking about them or thinking about
them that's a little bit of truth but
truth encompasses so much more it's part
of a a system and it also has to take
account of the truth understander or
truth bringer that is the subjective you
know object the self-consciousness which
then of course brings in other people so
this it gets very complicated very quick
but I just wanted to sort of throw that
out there in this first sentence
so what does he say after this the the
translation is a little bit misleading
at this point Miller's translation
because he says it is and it is a Thorat
ativ which means that it sounds like
it's you know speaking with authority or
something along those lines there's
nothing like that going on here the
German is assist and you know the verb
is Galton s galloped right it it holds
it is valid it it attests you might say
to what is being said you know we we use
that term for when something you know
and we can say it's authentic
authoritative authentic either one of
those works I would really just prefer
to say it is valid or it it holds or it
provides what it says that it does he
says in the sense that it exists and is
authoritative in and for itself and what
are we talking about there what's the it
the it is what we just looked at in the
previous paragraph and also the
paragraph before that that ended the
last section the absolute matter in hand
which now is no longer something
extrinsic to the individual but is
something that that is integrated or you
might say the individual is integrated
within it so the absolute matter in hand
the absolute absolute zakah he's not
saying Zack has helped stat this point
in part because I don't think he
actually needs to so he says it is the
absolute matter in hand which no longer
here's a key point no longer suffers
from an antithesis or opposition between
these different things and what is the
antithesis ultimately between the
universal and the individual but Hegel
will frame it in terms of certainty on
one side which I think you can hear
associate with the universal or it might
be able to you might be able to switch
it over to this
and then truth on the side of the
individual it all depends on which sort
of perspective you're adopting on it but
there is this tension there that now has
been brought within the scope of the
absolute so they're no longer merely
opposed to each other there's no longer
an antithesis in this in the sense of a
stopping point look pick one or pick the
other right it's now that they they
exist in in opposition or tension but
within the scope of the absolute matter
in hand the other way that he talks
about it is in terms of purpose and
reality this should make us think back
to all of this discussion about the
nature of human action and the fact that
the purpose or intention that's vak or
sometimes translated as the end right
rarely turns out to conform exactly to
the reality when we attempt to take it
from the merely ideal and realize that
yeah great example there are these
videos nothing ever turns so quite like
I I expect them to you know I used that
as an earlier example in one of the
videos now he says it no longer suffers
from this antithesis of certainty and
it's truth between universal and
individual between purpose and reality
instead this is the absolute matter at
hand has its existence is the reality
and action of self-consciousness
so it's self-consciousness here that is
in fact connecting the universal and the
individual and this makes sense one of
the important aspects of
self-consciousness is precisely the fact
that through our reflexivity our
relation to ourselves we are able not
just to see ourselves in terms of you
know some sort of pure individuality but
in terms of universals and
in relation to other people which means
in relation to other self-consciousness
you know they'll give you an example the
mere act of wearing a tie right so I
picked out this tie today in part
because I like the way that it looks you
know the gold against the blue probably
has to do with the fact that not only is
it a nice color combination but I went
to you know several different schools
where blue and gold were in fact the
colors first you know my elementary
school where it was really about this
sort of color and then my high school
wear was a more yellowish gold but it's
still blue and gold nonetheless right so
you say well that's so that's so
subjective dr. Sadler yes
but the notion of wanting to wear
something that matches takes me already
from the realm of purely individual
sentiments and perceptions and
sensibilities into something that while
it may not be totally universal I am
certainly treating it as universal and
notice that all the stuff that we said
before about content and form fits into
that you know this is the content this
color this color but the form is
something like picking things that match
and you can abstract that away from any
determinate sets of colors although you
can't really drive the point home
without introducing some colors so that
provides I think a useful example let me
give you another example that again has
to do with the tie I picked out this
time in part because I you know it's a
matter of course I wear a tie and
usually a jacket sometimes a sweater or
something like that
when I create these videos so it's sort
of my uniform but I get to pick what tie
and what shirt and what jacket I'm going
to wear out of the the lot that I've got
in my closet now that's all on the side
of the individual yet what's the deal
with my wearing a tie
I am by virtue of establishing this kind
of consistency which is you know a
decision on my part doing something
that's more universal I'm in some
respects introducing the universal in
the process of universalizing by wearing
a time so these are some really really
trivial examples but I wanted to use
that because it drives home how deeply
rooted what Hegel is talking about
really is this tension this ongoing
tension between universal and individual
in in terms of the matter at hand all
right back to the text now after our
excursion into haberdashery right first
time I've ever used that word in a video
all right so he goes on and he says it's
the absolute matter in hand it no longer
suffers from this antithesis right and
this matter in hand is therefore what
the ethical substance something that we
thought we lost so many sections ago and
have been seeking ever since ah we've
got the ethical substance we have our
hands on it we're at least pulling at
the hem of the robe right and so he goes
on and he says not only do we have here
the ethical substance the matter in hand
as the ethical substance but the
consciousness of it is the ethical
consciousness so we are grasping the
good here in the matter in hand in a way
very different than how we begin in
talking about our own project in the
matter in hand we also have it as the
true
he says for it combines self
consciousness and being in a single
unity now notice that the the true has
been talked about in several different
complementary ways here here he's saying
it's combining self consciousness and
being in a single unity there what we're
talking about is something
more similar to the notion of truth as
ad equation right you know or
correspondence ad equation between the
being the sign and self-consciousness
but now it's not just consciousness of
being its self-consciousness of being in
a unity right again what's the unity
this is this absolute matter in hand the
other way that he talked about it was be
that it is and is authoritative right
that you know it has being or it exists
and it is valid right now if we go on he
says this has the value of the absolute
self consciousness cannot and does not
want anymore to go beyond this object
self consciousness rational self
consciousness has arrived at something
that it looks like it could be content
with and he goes ahead and he says why
connect go why can it not go beyond this
it is all being and all power all being
and all power everything is contained
within it it does not want to for it is
the self or the will of this self so at
this point if the phenomenology were to
stop right here it looks like we have
something that we have been seeking this
entire time doesn't it
Hegel never stops like that though now
we go on and introduce something else
that looks at first as if it's going to
make everything even better even more
comprehensible but what we're doing here
is sowing the seeds of the dissolution
of the absolute matter in hand the
absolute czaka by introducing a new kind
of individuos individuation that is also
one of universality you might say to put
it in other terms we are now going to
talk
about universality in in in terms of
universalities in the plural this should
remind you of the force in the
understanding section so he says the
object is its in its own self realist
Incan characteristic of consciousness
what is the distinction characteristic
of consciousness it tells us it divides
itself consciousness is a unity and yet
is also a plurality bound together in
that unity and as soon as you introduce
plurality we can now once again have
antithesis coming up as we're going to
see so he says it divides itself into
masses Mawson or spheres and so you know
it's just the same word Mawson right we
could call them masses we could call
them spheres I actually would prefer the
word domains if we're thinking about you
know the ethical substance and the sorts
of things that it applies to because if
you look ahead to the paragraphs yet to
come the examples that Hegel uses are
things like truth-telling
or benevolence you know these would be
sort of determinate domains of the
ethical substance and Hegel is going to
call these determinate laws of absolute
essence the shrimp thing is that
absolute the absolute Vaes all right
absolutely so what do we have here well
these are the ways in which the matter
in hand now understood is the true and
understood as the good as ethical
substance is made more concrete it's put
into application you might say so he
goes on and he says these masses don't
obscure the notion not yet he's right
for the moments of being and pure
consciousness and of the self remain
enclosed within it this is a unity which
constitutes the essence of these masses
right the absolute essence and which in
this distinction no longer lets these
moments fall apart from one another well
this sounds pretty awesome
this sounds like we've finally attained
what it was that we didn't realize we'd
been seeking until about halfway through
the reason section which is to find the
ethical substance which is also the true
now at this point in the phenomenology
everything is being held together but
it's an unstable tension as we're going
to see in the paragraphs yet to come
you